today I'm going to show you one of
Mexico's most popular cocktails and no
it's not the margarita it is the lesser
known and perilously refreshing Paloma
for this cocktail you're going to need
some Blanco tequila a couple lime wedges
a pinch of salt and some grapefruit soda
we're going to start by building this
right in the glass kind of the way you
would a gin and tonic or a rum and coke
so we're going to start with two ounces
of Blanco tequila there are three major
kinds of tequila Blanco Reposado and
Anejo
Blanco means white and it's barely been
aged at all the Reposado means rested
means it's been aged for up to a year
has a slightly yellow ER color and then
an yaho means aged and has spent about
one to three years in a barrel it's more
complex and has more of an amber color
but for mixing really refreshing
cocktails like this or a margarita
Blanco is the best way to go all right
so we're gonna fill this glass with ice
threw in a pinch of salt right over the
top you'll see some recipes that call
for a salt rim I just like to throw it
right in and now a lime wedge which
we're going to squeeze over the ice and
just toss it in and now we're ready for
our grapefruit soda there are not that
many grapefruit soda brands around in
the US market there's some really good
mexican brands out there if you can find
those but if you can't find any you can
also substitute some grapefruit juice
agave and soda water so just do an ounce
of grapefruit juice half an ounce of
agave nectar and top it with soda stir
it up finally finish it off with the
language that is the Paloma your summer
alternative to the margarita what's your
favorite drink tell us in the comments
below
you